Hurricane Katrina may extend from
Southeast Louisiana all the way into
Kentucky
you blacks from the Lower Ninth
[Music]
well knew you've locked down I don't
know how you do it I think it's love man
we got a wife and a son now you won't
have to deal with this type of
assistance the 9th Ward isn't covered
nothing short of apocalypse first they
flood then they pushing herself this
happened just how they won't why don't
we talk to your cousin that dude again
saying he made me nervous
then what the hell are we we ain't no
gangster he's following the option just
wanted on first all right
we ain't that different many foot of
money
perfectly good hacks paying casino was
hit drink got my money
we got to walk the place we gotta figure
something out fast
you got trouble boy
you're recognized would you what would
yes like it's going on
as we do so we got problem
[Music]
I think they in trouble is it war going
on you don't know about
definitely got down when the Lord knife
wasn't mine long before I was jealous
[Music]
Katrina has always been wettest set a
bunch of different names
[Music]
you
you